su columna vertebral está compuesta de
huesos individuales llamados vértebras
su columna vertebral forma un túnel de
protección llamado canal medular
que rodea la médula espinal a la vez que
baja por toda la longitud de su columna
vertebral
a cada lado de la médula espinal los
nervios espinales salen del canal
medular a través de canales pequeños y
óseos llamados foramen neural
su columna lumbar es el tercio inferior
de su columna vertebral
entre cada vértebra una flexible llamada
disco vertebral actúa como un
amortiguador de su columna
y la presión del disco lumbar puede
aumentar más de un 50% cuando uno cambia
de una posición de parado agachado
o más de un 80% entre la posición de
parado y sentado sin apoyo para la
espalda
el resistente anillo exterior del disco
en vertebral es conocido como anillo
fibroso
el centro suave y tipo gel se llama
núcleo pulposo
en el caso de una lesión traumática su
columna vertebral puede doblarse a la
fuerza lo que causa que su vértebra
comprima la parte delantera de uno o más
discos lumbares más allá de los límites
normales
como resultado la parte posterior de su
disco sobresale hacia atrás lo que causa
pequeños desgarros y el adelgazamiento
de su anillo fibroso
con el tiempo su anillo fibroso dañado
puede debilitarse y cambiar de forma
y su núcleo pulposo puede secarse y
perder flexibilidad a medida que su
disco en vertebral se deteriora su
núcleo pulposo puede empujar su anillo
hacia afuera lo que resulta en una
protuberancia del disco
dependiendo de su ubicación la
protuberancia puede empujar o afectar
sus nervios espinales su médula espinal
o su cauda equina que es un conjunto de
raíces de nervios espinales en el
extremo final de su médula espinal
y la protuberancia del disco central
sobresale hacia atrás en su canal
espinal
y la protuberancia del disco lateral se
extiende en su neural foramen
y varias lecciones del disco lumbar
pueden descargar su anillo fibroso
y la presión de su vértebra puede
empujar su anillo pulposo hacia fuera de
su anillo desgarrado lo que causa la
hernia de disco
un disco lumbar herniado puede afectar
su cauda equina o nervios espinales y
causar síntomas tales como dolor
entumecimiento o debilidad en una o
ambas piernas
el tratamiento para las lesiones del
disco lumbar puede incluir descanso
y medicamentos antiinflamatorios
y relajantes musculares
frío o calor aplicado al área lesionada
y terapia física
una inyección epidural de esteroides que
se coloca directamente en el área de
irritación del nervio
y en casos más severos la cirugía